flor quiere hacer mesas y sillas cada
mesa o silla está hecha con el mismo
número de tablas de madera y clavos
ella tiene un total de 150 tablas de
madera y 330 clavos la siguiente
desigualdad representa el número de
mesas y sillas sé que ella puede hacer
con 150 tablas de madera aquí vemos las
150 tablas de madera y por lo que vemos
ella usa 17 tablas de madera para las
mesas esta es la cantidad total de
tablas de madera que se ocupan para las
mesas y vemos que ella usa
6 tablas de madera para cada silla así
que este es el número total de tablas de
madera que se usan para las sillas y si
sumamos estas cantidades no puede ser
mayor que 150 ya que ella tiene
solamente 150 tablas de madera además la
siguiente desigualdad representa el
número de mesas y sillas que ella puede
hacer con 330 clavos aquí tenemos 34 por
el número de mesas por lo que esta
cantidad es el número de clavos que se
requieren o que se van a usar para las
mesas 34 clavos por mesa x el número de
mesas y vemos que ella necesita 27
clavos por silla esta es la cantidad
total de clavos que se usan en todas las
sillas que puede hacer y la suma de
estos dos términos no puede ser mayor
que 330
ya que es el número máximo de clavos que
ella tiene vamos a poner consistentes
los colores aquí
y nos preguntan tiene flores suficientes
tablas y clavos para hacer tres mesas y
nueve sillas tres mesas y
nueve sillas veamos el número de tablas
que damos que se necesitan 17 tablas por
cada mesa y 6 tablas por cada silla
bueno son 17 tablas por mesa y son tres
mesas serían 17 por 3 y con eso
tendríamos el número total de tablas que
se ocupan en las mesas y también va a
ocupar vas a agregar
6 por el número de sillas que va a hacer
así que tenemos
por nueve sillas 6 por 9 6 tablas por 9
sillas seis por nueve va a ser el número
de tablas en total que se van a ocupar
para hacer las sillas y esto es lo mismo
que tener 17 por 3 nos va a dar 51 más 6
por 9 va a ser 54 y esto será igual o
menor que 150
pues 51-54 base de igual a 105 y 105 es
menor que 150 así que esto se verifica
por lo que ella tiene el número de
tablas suficientes para hacer tres mesas
y nueve sillas así que tiene tablas
tablas
ahora qué pasa con los clavos ok tenemos
34 clavos por mesa y aquí se hacen tres
mesas 34 por 3
ese es el total de clavos necesarios
para hacer todas las mesas más 27 clavos
por las sillas y se tienen nueve sillas
27 por 9 y nos preguntamos si esto es
menor o igual que 330 34 por 3 es igual
a 90 más 12 es igual a 102 y tenemos 27
por 9 que es igual a 243 si a 243 y 102
más 243 es menor o igual que 330
102 + 243 es igual a 345 así que esto no
se cumple 345 no es menor o igual que
330 así que esto no es verdadero
no es verdadero por lo que los clavos
los clavos
son suficientes
los clavos no son suficientes
así que tiene las tablas suficientes
pero no los clavos suficientes así que a
menos que ella vaya a comprar los clavos
que le hacen falta no podrá hacer esto